there's a fine line we all must walk
when we communicate
we have to say enough to get our point
across but we want to avoid over talking
today we'll explore talking too much and
how to listen more
I'm Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome to think fast
talk smart the podcast
[Music]
today I look forward to speaking very
concisely mind you with Dan Lyons Dan is
a journalist author and sometimes
screenwriter he wrote for Newsweek and
Forbes and recently released his third
book
STFU the power of keeping your mouth
shut in an endlessly noisy world
welcome Dan I'm excited for our
conversation and I must admit very aware
of what I am saying I'm curious what
motivated you to write this book and and
how do we know if we're an over talker
it's a great question and
full disclosure I was motivated to write
the book because I talk too much and I
became aware of this and I became aware
that it had caused me problems in my
professional and personal life
and I set out to try to figure out well
why do some people talk too much
and how can you fix that and I started
doing research and I stumbled across
a concept called talkaholism that was
defined in the 90s a talkaholic is
defined as someone
who speaks even when they know what
they're about to say will hurt them even
when they know that it's in their best
interest to not speak they still speak
so it's a compulsion akin to an
addiction and there's a test you can
take it's in my book and I think we have
it on the web someplace too called the
talkaholic scale and maximum score is 50
and I go to 50. so I definitely had my
work cut out for me wow so this is a
book out of personal need and passion it
sounds like if we do learn that we are a
talkaholic what are two or three hacks
or bits of advice you could give us to
help us not talk as much
yeah I invented little games I have five
sort of tips but one of my little games
is just when possible say nothing which
is sounds insanely easy or maybe it's
always possible to say nothing but it's
not quite so easy and I'll try to
practice it in situations where I would
talk when I don't need to like I'm at
the grocery store and I'm checking out
and pardon me wants to say Hey you know
how you doing you know how's your day
going busy today huh and then how long
you worked it you know like I I all that
kind of stuff that it's all despite the
urge to do that another bit of advice I
have in the book and I've tried to live
by is to
get off social media or to spend as
little time as possible because I think
it's programming you to be agitated
which causes you to talk more and
another thing I've done that I really
recommend is finding ways to add silence
to your life for some people it might be
meditation for me it's been a practice
called Forest bathing which I write
about in the book you get a guide and
you go off into the forest and you sort
of drink up this benefit of the trees so
those are a few things I've found that
have helped me bring yeah some quiet to
my life which then helps me to talk less
so the key there is finding a way to as
you just said bring quiet and that then
reduces I guess the urge to fill the
space and to take up talk time
yeah
because we have that natural urge to
Jump Right In where we're not typically
not good listeners and that's the other
thing I've really practiced on and one
of my five points is learn to be an
active listener and so I've I will
sometimes go into a conversation
resolving beforehand to only ask
questions good questions and then listen
and then not do the thing where you're
speaking and I'm just waiting for you to
finish so I can say my thing but to
really just have no agenda
to let you speak
and ask just respond to what you say to
mirror it back or or ask a question to
help you continue where you were going
it's selflessness which is more natural
to some than others I guess but yeah
it's about putting the other person
first so not only do you put the other
person first but it sounds like you
really double down on listening and what
I heard you say is while I'm not having
an agenda while you're receiving the
information from the other person you
actually go into these situations with
some questions or ideas that you want to
to bring out of that conversation so you
put yourself in a position where you can
listen is that what I heard correctly
yes that's it and then you want to
resist the urge to have that list of 10
questions I mean this is more for when
I'm doing an interview with someone
saying so I have a very definite agenda
I need to get something but the other
thing where you have question one
question two question three and you ask
question one and the person sort of
answers the question but in the course
of doing that says something really
interesting that
if you were really listening you'd go oh
wait a minute what's what's that and
you'd let yourself
digress rather than just going okay good
answer let's go to question two it's
almost like improv there's this idea one
way to learn to listen is to do this
this thing in improv they do called yes
and where
it's all about listening and whatever
the other person says you say yes and
and continue that so you can't really go
into that improv skit
with a plan the one key nugget I want to
take away from what you said about
listening is you're listening not just
to respond you're really listening to
understand and that's a mindset shift
for me personally and I think for many
of us and I really appreciate that and I
have to remind myself of that that if I
really want to connect with you I have
to listen to understand I'm not just
listening to get enough information so I
can say my next piece I want to ask a
question that I'm very curious about as
we've been talking is there a difference
between over talking and verbose writing
do those who talk too much tend to write
too much too and are there different
bits of advice you would give depending
on the venue of our verbosity I don't
know if you could say this a direct
correlation between everybody who's an
over talker is also an overwriter
however I do think boy those two often
you do find them in the same person and
I think
overriding is just as bad as over
talking it's been easier for me to deal
with it I'm can be pretty brutal when I
edit my own stuff I can go back and
really cut it well you're doing that
after the fact I've done some work
talking with people in business
communicating in a professional setting
and I encountered a guy who would have a
weekly one-on-one with his team
and would just get on the call and talk
for half an hour and maybe say let me
share my screen and let me show you some
slides and eat up the whole hour and
then time's up and then
when he wrote he would write way too
much I started talking with him about it
and he said something I thought was
really interesting which is that I think
I talk too much because when I'm with
the people I manage I need to prove to
them
that I'm smart I deserve to be their
boss and don't worry everybody I've got
under control and here's what we're
doing
and when I'm in a meeting with my
superiors
I feel like I have to earn my seat at
the table and look at all the stuff I
know and look at how much value I add
etc etc
and I thought well yeah so it's I guess
it's driven by insecurity and it
requires a certain amount of confidence
to not indulge that way we've had a few
fellow colleagues at the business school
who study power Deb grunfeld Jeff
pfeffer have come and they've talked
about how silence is actually a way to
increase your status and power those who
have status and power are permitted to
be silent and it sounds like the person
you were coaching and working with could
use some of that advice it's not all
about the talking it's actually about
the the not talking that can give you
that status and power the one thing that
we can do in writing that we can't
necessarily do in real time in speaking
is you can edit as you said you did we
could before we send out that email we
can go back and say is this clear is
this concise how could I make this
shorter to help reduce the verbosity
that I think many of us put in I think
many of us talk and write in almost a
stream of Consciousness way and I think
if we reflect and edit we can do
ourselves a service and those who have
to suffer through all of those words to
your point about power
Bob Green Robert Greene wrote this book
the 48 Laws of Power and like one of the
top ones is powerful people always say
less than they need to
and I was talking to Scott Galloway
recently he was saying it's the ultimate
Flex like silence being able to sit
there
is like such a flex right and it could
be mean if you're doing it just to make
people uncomfortable because people get
very uncomfortable very quickly with
silence absolutely so Dan I'd like to
I'd like to look at the other side of
the interaction what advice do you give
to those of us who have to deal with
people who talk too much how do we shut
them up you buy them a copy of my book
and you leave it under a desk and
they're not around that's it now you get
you in a fat fastball right over the
middle of clay no so yeah I mean it's a
delicate situation I believe that most
people though who talk too much know
that they talk too much they're aware of
it and often they wish they could
not do it they're aware that it's a
problem and they just don't know how
to do that and they're
I think sometimes depending on your
relationship with the person you can
sort of in a conversation bring it
around to that
and it's like you do trying to talk too
much and you could listen more and
bring it up in a supportive way I think
the worst one of The Interrupters though
and
how do you how do you deal with them and
in one chapter I talk a lot about it
there are a lot of ways to deal with an
interrupter and there it's very
situational give me an example of one or
two how do you stop somebody from
interrupting like I just did there to
you well see that's like that's a good
Interruption I don't think all
interruptions are bad that was in a way
saying Dan you kind of you've been going
on here let me help you bring you back
it's a conversational skill right but
one thing I think is a really great idea
is at the beginning of a meeting
you just set the ground rule up front
which is that
we're going to have this media we're
going to let everybody talk I want to
let everybody have a turn and a full
turn
before the next person jumps in of
course that does open up the policy
really to someone to do what I do just
ramble you so you could add the caveat
that if you're rambling I will help you
come to the point but that way you've
set that rule up front so then if
someone does it you say ah okay we
remember we said oh right okay fine I
mean so there are polite ways to handle
it the other good one is to pull someone
aside someone who's a chronic
interrupter and just say hey look I
don't want to embarrass you in private
group I want to run something by you
that I often coach people to do and I
learned this in one of my son's
kindergarten class I was helping in the
classes sometimes parents do and the
kindergarten teacher left in chaos
ensued she had to take a phone call and
I was the only adult in the room in
moments chaos ensued and I'm trying yeah
Johnny stop that Sally's and she walks
in sees the chaos takes a deep breath
and she simply starts rewarding people
she says Rachel I love how you're
sitting still and Sam I love how you're
you're playing with the scissors of pro
appropriately and everybody just got
back into in into shape and and I I
often will advise people in some of the
situations you're just talking about is
highlight when they do something well so
when somebody says something concisely
and clearly say that was really helpful
how you said that so clearly so you're
not saying you talk too much all the
time you're highlighting when they do
something well have you used that as a
technique and is that something that's
useful do you think in these situations
yeah I think that's an incredibly good
idea I have not ever used that but it is
positive reinforcement right and I think
it also sets the template or a model for
everyone else to say wow
that was amazing you just made that
point so concisely and even look around
it did everybody you saw that right that
was great and then now that's just let's
all aspire to to do that in your book
you cite some fascinating evidence about
the mental and physical benefits of
being a good conversationalist how do
you define a good conversationalist and
and what are some of those benefits that
you write about
I'm so glad you mentioned that because I
thought it was the most interesting
thing in the book and I thought it was
the thing that everyone would be talking
about in this book and yet hardly anyone
ever brings it up but this the story the
chapter about this psychologist named
Matthias mail
who was at University of Arizona and I
came across his work and it blew my mind
so
he spent his entire career studying
speech and its connection to emotional
and physical well-being
his
primary thesis being that speech is so
integral to who we are that it must be
connected to other things in our life
and so he he did studies and found that
people who have good conversations tend
to be happier on average than other
people they did the same experiment or
similar experiment but instead of
measuring
good conversations to
self-reported scores unhappiness
measured it to immune system and found
that people who have good conversations
also have healthier immune systems which
leads to his
Theory which hasn't been proven yet that
you could then do things in reverse and
say if you have more good conversations
you can make yourself happier and
healthier and his thing is like take two
conversations and see me in the morning
or something you could prescribe
conversations as medicine now
the great question you asked is what is
a good conversation and at first when he
was telling me this I thought oh this
destroys my thesis because he's saying
talking is great go talk talk a lot they
said well no because a great
conversation
is about listening it probably involves
you talking less but asking good
questions and
the one example he used to me was the
difference between saying hey how are
you I'm going no how how are you I
really want to know about this
so yeah it's a good conversations about
and it basically he caused a meaningful
and substantive so the conversation we
we're having is a good conversation I
don't know if you've ever been in a
social situation where for whatever
reason maybe nobody knows each other
well everybody or this people are too
afraid to really get real about anything
or be authentic so the entire
conversation remains very very
superficial and after which you almost
feel like
like hungry or like that was it's it's a
it's a weird bad feeling it feels empty
yeah for sure yeah for sure I think
that's fascinating that conversation can
impact our health and even disposing the
hypothesis that using conversation to
help yourself feel better and be
healthier I think that's wonderful and
clearly for people who do what we do
that's great all of a sudden there's a
whole other level of benefit good
communication provides
so Dan before we end I'd like to ask you
the same three questions I ask everyone
who joins me are you ready for that I am
ready and ready to go all right here we
go
if you were to capture the best
communication advice you ever received
as a five to seven word presentation
slide title what would it be can I only
use four because I would say talk less
say more
perfect and as somebody who talks about
talking less I think it's very
appropriate to have fewer and based on
everything we've talked about that makes
a lot of sense talk less listen more you
have had an opportunity to interview and
speak with lots of people so I'm very
curious to get your answer to question
number two who is a communicator that
you admire and why
I've always thought Barack Obama was
a fantastic Communicator in two
directions one is that he is
terrific at giving speeches and you can
study his speeches and learn from them
but then he is also a phenomenal
listener apparently an even better
listener than he is
a speaker and I think maybe in second
place I would say Steve Jobs and if you
want to see a master class and public
speaking just watch the iPhone
introduction which you can see on
YouTube and I write about it in the book
yes absolutely absolutely and number
three what are the first three
ingredients that go into a successful
communication recipe first I would say
empathy and and mirroring so somehow
engaging with the person and letting
them know that you feel empathy with
them
the next one would be listening I feel
like that's that's probably number one
really and related to empathy
and I think the third thing would be
trust and somehow building
a sense of trust between you
establishing a feeling of trust
is a is a big ingredient to a great
conversation absolutely and I think
empathy and listening build trust could
you explain for a moment a little bit
more what you mean by mirroring that
might be a New Concept for some of our
listeners so there's this FBI technique
of getting people to talk by literally
saying whatever the last three or five
words they said
that and then
starting with that but mirroring I mean
basically someone says something and
it's different than I went to Hawaii and
like or I went to Hawaii too it's it's
that someone says boy I really had a
rough day oh my God like my wife had a
very rough day it's the end of semester
and I found that all I had to say was
wow you had a really rough day
wow and she told me this guy I was like
wow that is
wow I can tell you're really upset
just observing right being a mirror
right just observing
and and of course that builds trust and
it builds empathy because then she goes
yeah you get it like you understand I'm
like yes I do so it's really reflecting
back what you're hearing and I actually
taught ninth grade for two years many
many years ago so you can tell your wife
that I have complete empathy for what
she she's going through at the end of
the semester it is insane and so so I am
glad she has you to to be her mirror and
to empathize with her Dan thank you so
much I appreciate all of your insights
and tips and guidance that can really
help us to have better conversations to
listen more and for those of us who need
it to talk less I wish you all the best
with your new book STFU the power of
keeping your mouth shut in an endlessly
noisy world thank you again oh thank you
ma'am
[Applause]
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Ryan Campos and me Matt
Abrahams our music was provided by Floyd
Wonder for more information and episodes
find us on YouTube or wherever you get
your podcasts thank you and please make
sure to subscribe and follow us on
LinkedIn